hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
give me a second I need to remember
exactly where I'm failing but I didn't
want to sit there and be pause with it
because I would be cheating accordance
with my stupid arbitrary rules that I
made so temperature is not the worst in
the world you could choose actually
getting oh yeah crank it crank it you
could do why are you so upset
is it because you're stressed as hell
it's probably cuz you're stressed as
hell you know what actually I'm gonna
disable all these if this is how there's
gonna be because apparently we don't
need that much air which is good cuz we
got so much I'm not gonna worry about it
too much I'm gonna open these back up to
polluted water and that way they can get
started with that we're doing good on
food who got 51,000 they increase the
quantity that you could put in the
refrigerator that is beautiful they are
beautiful for doing that our water
situation is dire but not that bad we're
gonna crack through this eventually
which means that we're gonna get to the
ocean then we can make the desal and as
a tour all good and ready to go and then
home then if everything goes according
to plan we will be in decent shape not
great shape decent shape so with that
being said you could choose still HAP
unhappy not happy unhappy at least we've
got tons and tons of oxygen which is
good and the heat is 29.6 there it's uh
28.6 there which is actually I think
less than it was that's still warm and
that's still producing a heat that's
producing heat that's producing heat I
would rather not have those there but I
have those there so nothing I could do
it bad now the situation is also better
with this considering that the coal is
doing okay but it's not doing that okay
apparently once we get the ice here we
have a good bit of ice going then I
think it's gonna be a little bit better
but I'm gonna worry about this first
yeah get it get it what did you just do
oh oh no no no no no no no I can't pause
I can't pause he's really oh you could
she's really grumbled and let me go too
slow then oh you could she was not doing
so good you could choose looking really
from bold okay you could - yeah I know
you're not doing so hot you could use
real
from her she's ready to fight somebody
that's all right you could do you're
gonna be fine don't worry about it it
looks like the polluted air also is kind
of made its way out of here
the carbon dioxide is still a little
problematic and it's flowing but yeah
it's all right
germs how we doing on germs not great
that's last less-than-ideal that's not
good I don't like that because
apparently that grows in polluted oxygen
a lot and I don't know why I wasn't
doing it before but germs okay it it
dies on regular oxygen so it does die
and regular oxygen but it grows in
polluted oxygen so that doesn't make the
most sense of the world but I'm not
going to worry about too much we're
gonna put this down soon boink and then
Shoom and then I'm just gonna get this
started so that we have it that's how
that's gonna start I just definitely
have a door here why don't I have a door
here why don't I at least have a
deodorizer over here because I'm stupid
that there and then I guess considering
this is a slime biome I should put a
deodorizer over here too probably right
there we'll be fine hey you know
everything y'all Turner you're so
stressed Oh Turner so stressed all-wise
Turner stress Turner please come on low
morale oh no oh no also I gotta get
these guys showers I'm not being very
efficient about my utility of the space
in here considering this big empty
stupid thing right here but you know
it's it is what it is and there's
nothing that we can do about it where
are the goddamn hatches
where are the hatches oh one more
hatches where the hatches at okay um
they would love a showers I would love
showers everyone would love showers but
I don't know if we're gonna be able to
get showers cuz they don't know if I
have enough showers for everybody also I
gotta make beds for everybody eventually
I know I got to do that I don't do that
enough I don't I don't treat my dudes
right I just don't do it and I don't
know why I guess I can make this area
the bedroom area
that might be nice but maybe not nice
who knows actually I want each of them
to have their own bathroom is what I
eventually want that's what I want I
want to make a nice big beautiful area
that they can all have their own
bathroom and they can all have their own
bed their own toilet their own
everything they're gonna have everything
that they need right then and there so
that they wake up they get a shower all
good in that neighborhood also I think
actually maybe this would be the best
area to do it just kind of like make
this the dormitory kind of thing lino
let's do it you know I'm I'm tired of
talking about I'm I'm gonna do I'm not
here to talk I'm here to do if I had to
not be stupid which is really
challenging for me I would do it like
not like that
if I had to do this I'm gonna do it like
this so what we have here extend it up
we're gonna extend this out we're gonna
put tile tile dig dig and a beet root
there but you know I'm not too worried
about that hey there's stuff buried in
here too hey didn't you stop buried
objects did these so I might be really
stupid about that calculating
calculating did they use that buried
objects out there I don't remember at
all I have no idea I actually don't
remember at all either way we're gonna
build that up there and that's gonna
eventually connect to the system that's
gonna be part of this wait a minute
yes that's gonna be part of this system
no no you stupid wire that's gonna be
part of that system in that way that's
all gonna be part of there and then I
can get rid of these and then make this
into the dormitory area so that we have
kind of a fireball fireball horrible
what do we get this fire pole when did
we get the fire pole oh that's cool all
right I'm down for that I'm down to
clown that's awesome and then eventually
I could make the new canteen up here so
that the food is more close to the place
that people go so people aren't always
running away from their beds to this
area
yada-yada you're not actually instead of
that I can make all of this instead the
dorm area because eventually I kind of
want to get rid of that that's no good
that's not being too bad of a problem
oxygen generation is still good goddamn
those are really pumped
up there's only nine of them and yet
they're producing enough oxygen that I'm
good yeah I guess I shouldn't complain
about it fine I mean okay we can get rid
of you now and we can get rid of you now
once those get built we can get rid of
those but let's start the base level
procedure for what is eventually going
to be the dormitory block just gonna
kind of be a grand sweeping thing like
that our bowl I love it I should also do
it here I'll be smart what what who what
huh high stress let's turn there crying
no what happened I don't have no idea
what happened is that that was a cutest
and also most sad wail I've ever heard
in my life who's being a little [ __ ] oh
that's that's a problem that I didn't
think I'd have what I could do is I
could eventually join these two together
I mean I don't know how beneficial that
would be but you know I yes none % sure
about this one but okay you know it
might actually work out nicely yeah what
are we gonna get ah gold amalgam or balm
lily seed I'll take the gold please I
like gold okay so they started digging
out that I'm gonna make it mostly out of
mesh I think we need like the oxygen is
so good in this area it's globally being
pushed through the vents so it's kind of
nice and working anyway let's let's
think of what the baseline unit for a
bed is gonna be I mean I guess you know
now that I think about it I guess they
don't have to be one away from each
other they can just be caught bathroom
shower I'm legitimately wanting to give
everybody their own like apartment
that's what I want I want them each to
have their own apartment that they can
work in you know I could even give him a
desk if I really wanted to I wanna make
this nice for them I don't think I can
maybe not I can't do that I can't give
them their own mess table because it
wouldn't be efficient
I do kids still want to make it
efficient but I can give their um their
own bathroom and their own shower
there's no reason that I can't it's not
like it requires power to do that anyway
so why not do that right okay so if that
that is not an if
in space thing but it's efficient for
the heart you know what I mean
that feels good in my heart and I like
that the only other thing that I
probably have to do is I'm probably
gonna have them share like you're gonna
go through one privacy now that's
something that we can't afford just from
the amount of space that we have to work
with I can't exactly give everybody
their own space if I'm dealing with it
like that but you know I can do
something pretty good let me get
people's canoodling over here not so
long as everything is still okay
temperature-wise we're doing all right
ooh these are generating a lot more heat
than I was thinking there would be not
gonna worry about it be a coup as
everything's fine it's not fine
forever but it's fine for now
okay so now that I got that I can see
that I'm gonna make lava loli shall
wooly Shoom Shoom Shoom not that and
then put a bed there there's probably a
way to copy the layout of something like
this but now they're gonna have a nice
room a real nice room that's what they
deserve and that's what they're gonna
get oh [ __ ] I realized that there's a
bit of a problem
can we up the priority of these this
construction or else we're gonna run
into a serious issue here you okay and
then that will be one unit there you
have it and I can even put someone's
dorm right here about to be pretty good
once I build these I can get rid of
these and that means that you know we
don't have to worry about that sing I
think I showers they don't need sinks
what am I talking about
maybe I got these backwards then maybe I
should be sure now then that wouldn't
work
I'll have them get sinks into the mess
hall the mess hall will contain the
sinks and that way people don't have to
worry about they'll like they'll wash
their hands before they eat it's perfect
okay so I have now laid the foundation
for all of these to have everything that
they could possibly want and in doing so
what I've managed to do is I've managed
to create a elegant system that's going
to have beds bathrooms and showers and
ideally I won't even need to build
another pump because these things
technically are pumping water through
them I can co-opt this which is
producing clean water even though it's
got just a little bit of germs on it I
can use that water to pump it people
wash their bodies and poop out their
butts they won't notice the difference
everything will be exactly the same as
it was and none will be the wiser okay
that makes sense yeah I think it makes
sense so if it doesn't make sense then
I'm gonna learn when the error of my
ways very soon
hey we got more stuff here oh wow
these are terrible but we could get a
little baby bug or we could get stinky
now baby bug I know technically I'm
making nine of these rooms and
eventually I'll get one more person but
I'm just not ready for it yet and I
don't want everyone to die so we're
gonna try to avoid that okay those are
over there that's gonna create a lot of
over here but I 29 degrees on that
that's not good that's not good at all
it says insufficient oxygen generation
but we're actually still totally fine so
not worried about that I will need to
get above this right quick but only a
little bit just so I can do the piping
on the top of this everything else
should be hunky and dory okay man yeah
who's really good at digging you could
use like really good at digging
excavation 13 oh that's a lot of digging
okay so it's gonna take him a long time
to be able to do all that Turner still
not doing so good what I haven't Turner
stressed yeah I know
at least the stress is going down so
what I need to do next is I need to
build the mess hall which is gonna be
right here there's gonna be
grande mess hall lalala very grand
that's gonna have sinks that's what
we're gonna have we're gonna have actual
sinks in and out of it so that hopefully
we catch all the germs it needs to be
caught best tables on two three four
five six seven eight you know maybe I
made a mistake because these apparently
aren't even given the morale bonus of
the barracks and I forgot about you know
what no I'm not going to let this ruin
my dream of giving my duplicants their
own apartments that's what I set out to
do and that's what I'm going to do so
I'm gonna do that and then that's
literally all there is to it there is no
other way for me to exist except to do
this for my dupes my dupes get what my
dupes want and what my dupes want is
some goddamn bathrooms in their own
goddamn poop installs that's what
they're gonna get I don't care what
people say I don't care let them talk
let them say whatever they want about me
I'm not gonna let to stop me from doing
what I know I need to do I need to
provide for or over left too much poop
water oh ok hopefully that doesn't get
problematic yeah we could probably fit
more in there yeah it's fine plenty
definitely how's the temperature doing
down here oh I don't know if that's any
better or worse just it just is so
there's that okay I'm gonna let this run
for a bit they're snoozing but I'm gonna
let this go for a bit I'm going to hope
that nothing blows up cuz if anything
blows up I will be mad and if I'm mad
that will be enough of a preventative to
keep these things from blowing up but
just in case they do blow up I'm gonna
turn this off from being a sweeper I
think that's the only risk where I have
to blow things up except for the heat
which is getting real toasty and heal
good okay I'll be right back don't die
nobody died
we're not done yet either my god you
stupid people
why won't use her e the heck up and get
your goddamn new homes ready it's like
they don't want a new home maybe but at
least I guess the beds are there so I
can start assigning people imma give
this to you could shoot cuz you two is
really a go-getter yes you could choose
bed turner is the runner so turner
definitely needs to get up and Adam
meemaw I can't have meemaw running very
much I I mean me mom's gonna fall from a
great height
she's huge she could roll out of bed one
day she's just gonna take a tumble
they're gonna see a broken meme on down
here the ball so yeah me mom's gonna be
right there and we got tinkle - we got
hee-hoo we're gonna get beer dude and
then we're gonna put evil baby face way
back there and then good old dumpling
just below and that should be everybody
and then I can now get rid of these
which is interesting because now I have
this room that I represent sure what to
do with what can you do nothing now
we're getting full why why are we
getting full if there's a third
candidate in here that's not too bad you
guys suck no not yet not yet look at the
arbor seed and then we can we make a
tree oh you look a little grumpy oh you
guys look a little grumpy you gonna be
you're gonna be mean I bet they're gonna
be mean
[Music]
everything's still taking a while you
know I'll let it run I'm not even gonna
look at it now you're gonna paint it you
guys do whatever you're doing whatever
it is doing great
real proud of you guys real proud yeah
keep it up ya know yeah you're doing
great oh they're getting close they're
not the eye they're going to sleep but
they're going to sleep in their new beds
the mess hall is a little far away from
the bed so I think I do need to make
that over here that would be a good idea
and the sink idea is nice but at the
same time it stops me from having any
sort of a fridge situation I guess I
just have the fridge here and then
more chair for when we get 9 and then
not really worry about everything else
and then people still do their thing
thing and you know that's good
automation yeah automation that's right
I set them to task on automation
research which is interesting I have no
idea how automation is gonna work I have
a general sense of how automation is
gonna work refined metal stupid stupid
whatever ok refined metal is not gonna
refine metal is not gonna be too much of
a problem so we just need to research
the refined metal process and then we'll
get the refined metal it's the longer
that's all we have it's all good not
even doing to worry about it then
everything good here fruit I don't have
time to worry about that I'm not gonna
worry about it so whatever just finish
up these last few pipes so we can get
the gosh-darn water flowing when are we
gonna get the Ghassan water flowing in
i'm gonna actually get the water flowing
by going right cheer it's a little
sneaky pulling a sneaky on yeah oh yeah
I was gonna join these two together not
that I think it's the greatest idea in
the world but I've got nothing better to
do so why not I like bold moves and I am
nothing if not bold
I'm gonna go whole hog or no hog at all
that's how I roll granite why are you
making out of granite granite how much
granite do we have I guess it was the
most abundant material sure okay granite
pipes love it good use of our resources
okay one more cycle and we should have
everything that we need we just don't
have it right now yeah I know we're kind
of we're kind of a little low on poopers
I think that actually the poopers might
be a bit of a hindrance on our ability
to do what we need to do so what we're
gonna do is we're going to plug it in
even though this is probably gonna
overload ooh it's nice and overloaded um
why did I build so many of these things
I don't know I don't know
I don't know look you're rid of this who
needs it
you gotta be careful because we're just
gonna oh I'm gonna extend it that's
right I was gonna extend it anyway so
clutch just bill finish ah do I need to
put a yellow alert here because I will
anything do to pee wee poopoo out put
him job put him doing it who did it too
late now then put a yellow alert on
these bad boys I know this isn't
technically a yellow alert it's just a
higher priority but whatever it's just
so close to being done and I want it to
be done how we doing on temperature not
good because these things making it hot
where I'm trying to I'm so stupid why
would I make it hot right by where I was
trying to cool it down why would I do
that because I'm dumb the only answer
there is there's literally no other
answer because I'm dumb that's it I'm
not even insulating where I need to
insulate it because I'm very stupid why
am i stupid I don't know my brain is
very stupid okay okay
hey oh come on you're so you're so
you're so almost there buddy hey new
friend time you know it we got Bonnie
and then gene nope
sorry guys not today unreached
unreachable build but why though it
should not be that why is that
unreachable I don't know about that one
but whatever we're gonna make this
yellow alert priority because I freaking
yeah it's some serious [ __ ] so get it
done douches
okay we're go to bed do you want to
maybe read ler ah now that'd be bad I
don't need to do that that's it's a
waste for the next day hey why is our
hatch hatch die probably cuz it didn't
have a hatch friend to make hatch babies
with is that what the deal is that might
be what the deal is how are you guys
still alive
yeah I know overcrowded cramped and
groaned glum I I'm I get it got nothing
to do for you guys are these things in
there
weird are we done yet yellow alert
yellow alert yellow alert yellow alert
top priority yellow alert unreal
[Music]
right it's of course it would be right
where are you going what are you doing
don't get out of there but now we've got
water and it's gonna take a bit for the
system to really get the water flowing
good but we've got water where we need
the water ready to go at your disposal
everything's good baby everything is
good
I really gotta build pipes better for
the better distribution cuz I don't do
that cuz no it's all clumping up at the
bottom so those I mean it's gonna clump
up anyway
which is good cuz I want these decline
yeah it'll be fine it'll be fine like
the demand isn't gonna ever be high
enough that it's gonna really offset it
all that much so I think we're good
there this will work the apartments are
open for business now I'm gonna make
bath time be first because for the first
time in a while it makes sense and then
downtime in the beginning nice morning
downtime easy peasy
then work then downtime then beddy-bye
three hours hey it's working it's
working the poop inators working look at
the poop go the Papa nation the poop
nation is happening a maximum poop -
dude so what we need to do now is we're
gonna actually destroy this we're gonna
hook this up to this right there we're
gonna destroy this actually and then
move all the food into here all the
edible and then things will be looking
pretty good this thing is just chock
full of ice fullest huge throbbing with
ice it is going pretty good guys it's
going pretty good I'm real happy with
this okay so what I'm gonna do now is
I'm going to crank me back down to
normal speed because now the major
construction project is kind of over
gonna deconstruct this we're gonna build
tile to block this off oh no oh no oh no
oh no I've
No that's a lot of poopy
it's a lot of poop guys Oh poop I didn't
put sing
it's okay alright I got it so the people
in the front they aren't gonna have
bathrooms per se they're gonna there's
gonna be sinks here and that will solve
the problem but also it kind of ruins it
but also it doesn't kind of ruin it it's
okay actually so I think it'll be
alright it's fine
it's totally fine is totally fine
everything is fine but it's also
horrible cuz now it's fine it's not that
big a deal it is totally a hundred
percent fine I'm being finicky over
nothing you just gotta build these sinks
then we're good to go calling
achievement earned what I do good egg
hatch a new critter more from an 8 what
happened what did I get what good egg
did I get what egg what an egg did I
hatch I know I did it I knew I was great
at this I knew I was great I'm the
greatest outside of stable uh-oh hatch
has escaped but I don't know where to
all right so this is fine oh where are
you going are you going all the way up
there well whatever okay that doesn't
make a whole lot of sense
you probably didn't get enough stamina
back oh yeah you didn't get enough
stamina bag are these guys not getting
enough stamina back no you're fine a
little more sleep I guess sleep in a
little bit
I kind of sign these showers the people
are they just gonna use it oh that's
cool though they're using the things
nice whoo what missing fiber fiber since
when did I need fiber
what's fiber fiber okay whatever okay um
it's pretty good so far I'm gonna get
rid of these because these guys are
gonna use those and I don't want them to
use that area I'm gonna finish out this
thing here we are going to have ladders
that extend down a bit and then once
they do that I'll crack that open so
that we have that spread out and then
I'll do a bunch more stupid stuff this
is good this is going good it may not
seem like it's going good but trust me
when I say this is going really good and
if it does seem like it's going good
then Hey
good you passed the test I was gonna
accuse you of not believing in me if you
didn't think that it was going to it so
it's going good so I'm gonna leave this
here for now pick this up in the next
episode I don't know why I'm so panicked
about
but I think everything is going good so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know I thought down the comments
below and if you feel like there's a
ticking time bomb it's because there is
it's getting really toasty and then soon
it'll be too warm to do anything but for
now it's good so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]